ciao a tutti benvenuti sono i
giornalisti serenità e oggi facciamo una
challenge che ci richiedete da
tantissimo tempo la neo no e sketch
avete richiesto tantissimo ultimamente
tipo la più richiesta smettila
ed è la keys challenge gli strascichi
come l'inter ha detto ciò la xvi
taleggio felice perché penso che deve
mangiare ma non come funziona perché so
che sono prima di tutto
allora in pratica uno alla volta dovremo
bendarci l'altra persona dove dovrà
mettere sulle labbra un po di un
qualcosa che cosa po di cose ognuno
sceglierà poi abbiamo anche cose
piccanti staccata l'altra pressione dura
dal rimbalzo
il brand opinare che cosa sulle labbra
in base a sapore supertramp in sé per sé
challenge non so perché vi piaccia così
tanto c'è l'abbiate richiesta così tanto
la parte sotto il nuovo aggiornare
movimento rete di como di prede dei pop
corn e lasciate un bel laiche
consigliate sicure altre ci ha pensato a
fare nei comitati carta forbice
i ribelli sono pronto andati bene
guardare non mi scendere la schifezza
decido io allora tempo migliore è che se
lo senti il rumore canta la canzone è mi
manca solo dai che manca solo il bruco
sola si vedono i due oleodotti l
impronta girati proprio passo verso
maggio
mi tolgo va bene mi sembrava già
indovinato la sera e senape
schifosissima ok allora vitale
indovinato quindi ora tocca a te per a
milano della immaginato tutto tutto
tutto ok
sono pronta qui pronta devo cantare la
canzone più che hai fatto
sono pronto
non sai niente questa cosa però ho
sentito tori di cocco
quindi visto che non si è sentito solo
filo tella visto che non sa di niente ho
sentito odore di cocco penso che stia
olio di cocco e sicura si ok di nutella
perché l'offerta dialogante aperto bravo
nel 2008 allora bendati si canta
non so che cosa cantare suggerisce con
una canzone
gli eventi che cartone come si fa per le
tavole gerry ha cantato ma io sono
stonato come una campana perché altro
possa fare un discorso aspettami devo
tirare giù la bella e cosa ti dico
allora nel frattempo che io che tu fai
le cose io parlo senza raccomando
questo caso cos'è gliela togliamo subito
il comando da buon winnie pooh è vero
fittare sembra quindi tocca piramidi
sotto permette di avere indovinato
quindi tocca a me se tocca a te a me a
te ea chi tocca a me
pino de sio debole nella pallavolo mila
penserà che del sentimento è sempre così
sarà per mille sia sempre così per mille
così via
il city
la so benissimo cos'è questo anche
perché hai scelto perché così se ne puoi
mangiare un po che cosa hai sbagliato
come la nutella
non è vero e nutella
no non mancheremo di mangia da mantenere
mangiato di nascosto registrato certo
dai dai fai un discorso quello che vuoi
cantata dolore ed allora che cosa vi
dico che racconta qualcosa visto che a
cantare non sono bravo di una città in
italiano
e se lo avete fatto vi siete iscritti al
mio canale grazie a questo video
scrivete un commento con vedono pronta a
volte cioccolato stilo pronta cioccolato
bravi dove robert a
[Musica]
che cos'è una cosa che io odio a 100
punti e alla certo vero c'è odore di
piede io odio la certo non so perché
puzza così tanto che facendo brutto ma
adesso non riusciremo più a riconoscere
i sapori e meglio sarà ancora più
difficile è comunque bravi non ha
nuovamente il regista in testa torkham
ok scattare
[Musica]
le proprie gambe
non so più chi ma in questa storia
poi c'erano le mermet made by author
prato bene ok
questa mano sembra miele ma acido e di
cura
c'è un mondo vi conosco
[Musica]
stranissimo miele al sito tipo miele è
andato a male
una volta e forse si rompa se tipo che
tipo di sciroppo si è rotto di frutta e
fruttate dottore è troppo dipingere
questo perché centro rumori di cose che
stai affittando non è che stai mangiando
di nascosto che sta orbitando sesto
ritardo la scatola il telethon barattolo
mettete del tempo al barattolo o no non
sto facendo nulla
non lo so che brutto e limone pesca
fragola e ciliegia
no nessuno di queste no io lampone
sciroppo di lampone sviluppo di frutti
di bosco
no more si fa lo sciroppo di rose
guardano bene marmellata di fornire
giustissimo cos'era marmellata reaper
nord danneggiata acida di ciliegia non e
pesca albicocca
finalmente
ma tutto cio non si può credere così non
lo posso fare
ciao a tutti vi mangiamo e contatterà
per muore raccomando è accorta che
presente scelte verso lo so io
canta parla mai qualcosa che a loro dire
non so che cosa devo dire
a prima vista meno di cento del mio
canale il canale digitale e allora
commentate con tu che cosa gli ho detto
di commentare prima un po non mi ricordo
oppure lasciate un commento scritto
faccio gameplay di pokemon l'ex topi e
ciò ti sims e forse qualcos'altro adesso
vedremo sei pronta aspettiamo tanto
[Musica]
per te perché mi sento subito maroni non
sopportava a brucia tantissimo last
rilancia e quindi che cos'è e la salsa
piccante delle cavani nei piatti
asiatici ed evitabile ancora attivi sono
arrivate le nostre labbra piccante aiuto
vi piace
povera per fortuna me ne sono accorto
subito e l'ho tolto e jam e brucia
figurati a tenere tenuta più tempo di me
[Applauso]
abbiamo due canotti possiamo mettere un
po di latte di olio di cocco magari
magari addio che ricadono nei 90
coroncina l'ultimo turno aiutami brutta
roba tantissimo detto che stanno per
morire non sostano gonfiando sono
bruciati parco adotteremo il tuo canto
campo nella malattia
[Musica]
si tratta pronta no dico io se sei
pronta in situ si sono pronto ma non era
una gela bra questo mio no aspettiamoci
però sta imparando media sulle labbra
bene ho scelto me cosa schifosa metti
credere strano hai messo di nuovo la
mischia ma l'aceto quasi cos'è accetto
no certo di di mandarla aceto di mele no
di si può essere al 100 di d
davvero invito per cosa si usa si usa
sull'insalata si usa sul fragole
parmigiano di modena pronti a marciare
come si chiama appunto l'aceto di modena
e aceto di modena fonti di gioco che
fatti quando l'ho messo nei pizzica mi
dava tutti i piccoli bruciati sul verso
le labbra mai capisco perché voleva temi
sociali perché può offrirci la xvi nei
commenti il tag stampo del momento che
aveva fatto più ridere a 10 io sto
morendo
fateci sapere nei commenti che altre
challenge se volete che facciamo anche
challenge madrid visto che ormai ne
abbia un probabile te e ora mi lasciavo
qua 4 castelli rispoli cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video le altre
challenge video divertenti cliccate su
quella che preferite è tutta la minzione
ciao